le batteur royal c'est devenu trop sans
fierté tôt par sid et enfin par là on
veux tu en voilà aujourd'hui une
nouvelle difficulté va se présenter à
nous essayer de faire tôt pas sur
téléphone mobile
en voilà une surprise
éblouissante parce que les lunettes j'ai
compris mes amis nous sommes sur pib
j'ai ce site une vidéo sponsorisé stld
marqué dans la description vous avez vu
le truc la communication commerciale la
lave la vue là vous le voyez encore
mieux maintenant voilà les amis en tant
que tu meurs je sais comment ça marche
un peu maintenant je sais que dans une
vidéo il faut toujours un fil rouge
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire comme fil
rouge
je trouvais attention c'est très
impressionnant original troisième pour
faire tokpa nous incarnerons cet homme
musculature omniprésente coupe de
cheveux très élégant style vestimentaire
sobre c'est parti pour jouer en un
contre sens comme d'habitude les trois
premières gammes qu'on fait sur ppj
contiennent énormément de bottes pour ne
pas tricher qu'est ce que j'ai fait sur
le trône ce matin j'ai fait trois gammes
de pbg mobile de manière à ne pas tomber
contre les bots ce serait de la triche
ce serait beaucoup trop facile on va
aller cher ami à pau chin qui on va se
régaler à poutine qui souhaite la folie
ok j'y vais vraiment le maire demande la
vidéo actuellement sous vos yeux
[Musique]
allez on passe du bon temps là mais j'ai
trop de style avec mon cas ce serait mon
afro ok atterrissage comptes volés on
ouvre immédiatement la porte et qu'est
ce qu'on trouve un pistolet des
munitions une chemise noire à fait
important le style tuer avec style c'est
très important arnal à poil au nez bien
elles elles portent chance c'est un
petit peu la trappe rêve de pbg si je
peux me permettre la poêle bien un mec
merde paniquez pas paniquer pas en fait
il a vu mon affreux vous avez vu il
avait gagné il a fait froid ou mais que
fais tu ici tu devrais sur le dancefloor
des boîtes de nuit les plus prisés de la
capitale
c'est pas des bottes à lacets que des
vrais joueurs dont mais j'insiste que je
suis inquiet du mérite hockey waouh
il est où ce bâtard à illéla regarder on
le voit moi je propose qu'on l'unique sa
grosse merde
oulala je veux avant de mourir faire top
1 / psg mobile c'est mon rêve
actuellement où vous l'avez vu vous
l'avez vu le sorcier le démon de ces
morts ben ça marche pas bien là il ya un
mec à droite et un mec à gauche on est
complètement pris un sandwich
rdv là il va venir vient au maire demers
a un sens où il a des couilles en or aux
jeux le buzz
il fut chassé yes ya un mec à gauche il
faut que j'aille albatar je me justifie
mais c'est pas des boîtes c'est par des
choix c'est moi [ __ ] j'me
ok ça va mieux merci papa nous avoir
appris à relancer mon coeur moi même y'a
plus personne là on est bien quelqu'un a
ravagé bout jean tigana et il se
pourrait bien qu'ils soient devant vos
yeux si tu vois ce que je veux dire
appelez moi le shérif de coaching qui
hausse était de sureau au liban c'est
là-bas clsh de voix ok je promets cool j
mais passons à la poêle mais qu'on a la
sainte poil on va se positionner sur ce
toit on sera indétectable parfaite oh
non j'ai pas rêver c'est un beau tout
quoi qu'est ce qu'il fout ta mais il
faut que je le dit mais qu'est ce que je
fais moi on y va on y va on y va on y va
[Musique]
j'ai maintenant tulard d'un âge en
passant est ça dégage allez on va au
colis passé nous ramène au mieux de la
zone en plus c'est très bien ok le colis
devraient être dans cette zone
vous l'avez vu je les ai vus j'ai vu on
l'a tous vu bougeait pas il va au drop
il est mignon il est mignon il connait
pas chefs de pôles chine qui al bataoui
l'épiderme pas l'attendre l'attend
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font ça il faut
qu'il joue quand même le mec et je lui
ball s'inquiètent
j'ai aucun respect je suis un chéri je
fais ce que je veux m'en bats les
couilles les amis petit bilan on a fait
cet qu'ils ont vient de se prendre un
arbre il reste quinze joueurs en vie on
à la zone et je pense que l'on va rester
en caisse on va essayer d'écraser de
trois mecs je vais en écraser un par
pitié aux ténors rire le rire moi rien
moi cette merde la balle waouh c'est un
joueur pro yes ok la boisson le calme où
cela je suis dopé comme un sportif et un
mec là olalalala medic 23 tu n'as rien
dame edith ni les soins ni le courage
mon ami à temps il y en a encore la
balle à tanger me le faire lui a gardé
le filet mignon ni trop mignon oh là là
dans la tête
ok on est plus que 2 le mec que je viens
tu es là il tirait vers la droite donc
le gaz doit être vers la barre haut mais
je suis en train de faire une patrouille
de chérif là mon chapeau c'est important
et nous apporté tellement chance là il
sait qu'il s'en sortira pas face au
sheriff de paul shin ki wan ok vous
l'avez vu j'ai vu on a tous mis
temmar crevettes
mios snipers
ok atteint faut jamais il faut que je
stresse les amis on peut le faire c'est
le duel du shérif j'ai pas où tu es
petite merde mais t'es foutu ok je t'ai
vu
[Musique]
aleman on donne l'argent on donne de
l'argent pour le bon joueur s'il vous
plaît allez allez allez tout dans le
chapeau on fait comme à l'église 22
[ __ ] le savez cela renchérit fait
capable de faire un truc pareil
après un top je vais pas vous mentir je
suis un peu frustré dorff et hop à la
première c'est peut-être la deuxième
sera forcément moins bien avant qu'on
fasse plus de kiel avec des moves encore
plus beau qu'on écrase des gens avec des
véhicules qu'on tue le nouveau shérif de
coaching qui ok on y va à l'âge propose
qu'on s'équipe tuera son délicieux des
années 80 attendez attendez pas pour toi
wima [ __ ]
tu as voulu faire quoi je suis dans la
merde c'est un mec pas loin mais il a
pas compris ce qui vient de se passer à
vider l'eau ok donc à 2015 à ma droite
est un homme
le faire tirer dessus dans le dos ça m'a
vraiment surpris ça m'a rappelé que je
t'es qu'une merde et non pas le chef de
plus chic
gamez
un ace par boire
j'appelle la tête scène slam ce qu'ils
font de jeu c'est sûr ils ont troqué mon
compte chic avec des bottes mais son
look il est où
waouh c'est boulot ok je te vois tu es
morte en plus ténu le buzz années 80 ils
sont là
ok je peux vous dire que j'ai la banane
sur la tête mais qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
aussi la banane ailleurs 1
à quand en jeu ça écoute de la musique
des années 80 ou pas par là parce que si
ça avait coûté pas de la musique des
années 80 je vais devoir intervenir les
mets se trouve là-bas dans un petit
cabanon nous l'avons vu un mec là aussi
je suis désolé je suis arrivé j'ai
entendu autre chose qu'une musique des
années 80 ça m'a très déplu à temps et
la résistance la résistance des années
2000 leur temps mais c'est quoi cette
plus de 1000 qu'est ce qu'ils écoutent
lui des fous je baise il ya deux matches
on a rien là bas
mais pourquoi vous tirer au fusil à
pompe à 7/10 un bot au oui tout mignon
dire un pokémon tanger de capturer ces
partis le combat est lancé je lance
boules de pétanque et c'est fini
vraiment trop mignon apron le problème
est dans la peau kemball voilà on va lui
voler son truc
alors bon bah direct sur la prochaine
zone à elle est loin heureusement nous
avons un véhicule où ils sont les
ouistitis là son seul je me sens triste
je tire ma perruque à toyer de voitures
la [ __ ] des pierres
l'asie tire tire tire tu as raison tu
iras les bonnes chances
mais pas nul n'est pas nulle poids la
tension entre les duels laisse-nous
toilettes nous toi tu es là tu fais quoi
t'es pas réglo à temps j'essaie de
l'aider comme je peux mais ok c'est bon
ok on parfois de parfois c'est bon
les membres français est-ce qu'il a tué
notre meilleur ami au jaï voire plus
tard ciao
je suis là je suis coincé john
[Musique]
je vais prendre ta chemise grise
assortie en souvenir notre amitié
tu es grand nord je suis coincé sous la
voiture
je vous mets stone ok c'est bon allez
piquer à la zone et la zone ya la zone
plus tard là là je suis dans la merde
c'est pas on va plus que la zone
iata a
ah [ __ ]
waouh tellement d'émotion dans cette
guerre allez un p'tit coup de soins et
on y retourne
ok on va dans celui là j'ai un agent qui
est un mec dans cette maison c'est moi
qui ai tiré les autres colis ça peut
être bien d'aller au colis là à un
ennemi en moins bien
merde oh merde t'es qu'une merde je
prends même 24 mai à tort n'est plus que
deux ans [ __ ] si je le tue avec un
sniper qu'elle va faire comme ça leur
apprendre la caisse va faire des rondes
mes cheveux sont tombés ces braves ne
t'es pas content car il a beaucoup
d'hommes à l'âge de 40 ans ou avant pour
le plus malchanceux comme par exemple au
lycée ou encore carlito non jure s'était
lui nom m'a exposé des morts mexes et
maintenant tu se joue toute la vidéo et
ce quoi finir sur une épique victoire
une grosse balle dans la tête au style
peur ou pas parce que la cour a indiqué
ok c'est maintenant
les graves bon [ __ ] a longtemps
[Musique]
mon
on
chers amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu évidemment
n'hésitez pas à aller mais si c'est le
cas en tout cas j'étais ravi de rejouer
un petit peu de battle royale à merci
athènes scène qui a autorisé la vidéo
merci beaucoup à eux savent pas d'argent
pour financer d'autres vidéos et ça
c'est très cool
un exemple celle des dix minutes qui a
du retard mais qui arrivera ne vous en
faites pas franchement jouer un bateau
rural sur mobile c'est très prenant
c'est différent c'est plus simple c'est
un peu moins de treillières franchement
c'est cool je vous fais des bisous à toi
de prochaines vidéos portez vous bien au
revoir
[Musique]